i'm about to sit down for a very large  christmas dinner um which will probably  contains a lot of food that i won't be  able to eat in about a week's time um so  i'll enjoy it because it's christmas if  i lost weight i think the main thing  would allow me to do would be to uh  play more sports i've always loved five  side football um tag rugby i played that  until fairly recently so we're here at  christmas morning uh i'm in the  beautiful welsh seaside uh happy last  walk on the beach  it's very good that i have an  opportunity to do this hopefully in the  new year there'll be a lot more of this  your blood pressure is very high okay  and i checked it repeatedly  and it remains high  did you know about this uh no i wasn't  aware now well it is serious and the  good thing is it can be treated okay but  it is related to weight as well yeah